-Our next guest is
a talented actress you know
from shows such as
"Big Little Lies"
and "The Society."
She stars as Cassie Lang
in the highly-anticipated
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania,"
which will be in theaters
and IMAX this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-You know I promised your mom
that you would only use
this stuff
when one of us was around.
It's really dangerous tech.
-I know it's dangerous.
-What if the cops took it
from you, huh?
What if you lost it?
-I didn't lose the suit.
-You have a suit?
Wait, you have a suit?
-I know how to take care
of myself, okay.
Trust me.
I'm pretty good at it by now.
-Ouch.
-Look, I didn't mean it
like that.
-I know.
-And I'm sorry.
-It's okay. It's all right.
I get it.
I just think you should get
to have a normal life.
-Dad, a guy dressed like a bee
tried to kill me in my room
when I was 6.
I've never had a normal life.
-Please welcome back to
the show, Kathryn Newton,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome!
-Hi. Thank you.
-You look wonderful.
-Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
-This is a very exciting week
for you last week.
-Yes.
-The film premiere party,
the launch.
-Yeah.
-Then you also had a birthday.
Happy birthday. Congratulations.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Happy birthday.
-I know, I feel
like I have never celebrated
my birthday so much.
-Oh, because everywhere
you went --
-It was my birthday.
The premiere was more
my birthday than my birthday,
you know.
I got the job, you know,
what, a year and a half ago now?
And that was like my birthday.
And then, you know,
they celebrated my birthday
on the press tour.
Everyone surprised me
on my birthday.
I had to go to Toronto
for a premiere,
and the whole audience sang me
happy birthday.
So if you want to, too,
like, I won't --
-I feel like it's a week ago
and I feel like we shouldn't.
-No, no. If you --
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Thank you so much.
I know you wanted to,
but it's fine.
-Do you like attention
on your birthday?
Because you're certainly
giving out that vibe.
-No, no.
-No?
-No, I don't.
Your birthday is, like,
the one day you feel like
everyone has to tell you
happy birthday.
So you -- I feel like you don't
really like me,
you just are acting like
you like me.
-You wouldn't want them
to say it on other days.
-[ Laughs ] I don't know.
I mean, that never happened
to me before.
-That's true.
-Yeah, I've never --
-We should start doing that
more.
-Just happy birthday, Seth.
-I feel like it's crazy --
-Yeah, happy birthday to you.
-Thank you.
-It's lovely to hear --
and I feel like I don't know why
we've kind of, like,
boxed ourselves
into only saying it on the day.
-Right.
Why would you do that?
-Yeah, why would you do that.
-When you could it say it
every day.
-Also it's fun because
now we share a birthday.
-Right. We could do it together.
-That's so much fun.
-We can have cake any time
we want.
-Oh my God, this is -- I feel
like you cracked the code here.
This is very exciting.
-I guess the real code is
if you can do a Marvel movie,
like, every movie, then
it's always your birthday.
-Yeah.
That's the important thing.
-Always.
-I mean, obviously,
a Marvel premiere is a little
unlike any other movie premiere.
-Right.
-Was it a trip to be there?
-It was insane.
I mean, I've been a part
of a fandom before.
I was on a show called
"Supernatural,"
and the fans are incredible.
-Yeah.
That's a real fan base show.
-That changed my life.
But then I went
to the Marvel movie premiere,
and it was, like, huge.
The fans are --
it's a huge family.
It's insane.
I saw some little Cassie Langs.
So that was crazy.
-People dressed up
in your costume.
-Yeah.
-That's very exciting.
-It was really exciting.
It felt real.
That's when it felt real.
-Did you feel as though people
treated you differently
on the set when you were wearing
the costume?
Let's just take a look
real quick.
Because I feel like -- look,
in the clip, you looked great.
But this is -- I mean, that's,
like, very impressive.
-I look a little different,
huh?
-Yeah.
Did you enjoy wearing the suit?
-Oh, I love wearing the suit.
Can't you tell that's why I'm in
a Cassie Lang suit?
I just am not done cosplaying
Cassie Lang.
I did my hair in a ponytail.
What I'm trying to say
is I'm a fan of Cassie Lang.
No, definitely people
treated you differently.
Like, they were a little quieter
around me.
-Oh, yeah.
-A little more scared.
-Uh-huh.
-I would be scared.
And everyone looked at me like
it was really me.
Like, they think that's
who you are all of a sudden
when you wear the supersuit.
and I promise you,
I fall just the same in
that thing as I do in this.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
I fell a lot.
-You're a faller.
Everybody says that about you.
-Oh, yeah.
I'm a tripper. I fall.
I'm just like Cassie.
Like, I was trying to figure out
how to be in a Marvel movie
and, like, impress everybody,
and she's a little young hero
trying to impress her dad.
We're very similar.
-There you go.
-Yeah, total messes.
-I would imagine Paul Rudd
is the perfect person
to spend time with.
Especially on your birthday.
I feel like every time
I'm with Paul,
I do feel like it's my birthday.
-I know.
That's what I'm saying.
You get it.
-Everyday is your birthday.
-Everyday was my birthday
on this movie
because of Paul Rudd.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he's the best.
He gave me a little gift.
It's actually from the movie.
-It's a prop from the film?
-It's a prop from the film
that I can't tell you about.
-Yeah.
-So...
Is it spoiler based?
-[ Sighs ]
-Or are you worried that Paul
will be arrested
for stealing a prop?
[ Laughter ]
-I think both,
now that you mention it.
-Yeah, I think both.
Now that we're talking about it,
I feel like you should not put
that man in danger.
If you're the reason Rudd goes
to jail,
no one here will forgive you.
-Marvel jail.
-Marvel jail, yeah.
-No, he did.
He made it special,
and I'll keep it forever.
-Okay. Well, that's very lovely.
-Yeah.
-I've talked in the past about
that you consider yourself
growing up,
you felt a little nerdy.
And then this is both superhero,
which I feel like superheroes
no longer have the sort of
nerd stigma they used to have
because they're very mainstream.
-Right.
-But also there's a great
element of science to this.
So did that scratch the nerd
itch, for lack of a better term?
-Yeah. Cassie Lang is a genius,
you know?
She's figuring out
the quantum realm and stuff.
So, after I finished the movie,
I didn't have a job.
I was very bored.
So I signed up for
a physics class at UCLA.
[ Laughs ] And I did that.
And I got an "A," thank you.
-Wow.
-[ Laughs ]
So we're the same once again.
-Oh, my God, you're her
and she's you.
You're the same.
-I know.
I'm just really method,
just like Jonathan Majors.
-Did the UCLA students
notice you when you started
taking their physics class?
-No.
I was hoping someone would.
-Is that safe to say
that you did not dress
like this?
-No.
I loved putting my outfits
on, though, for the class.
You know, like, I put on
my little blue light glasses
and, like, a sweater vest.
'Cause I didn't go to college,
so I really was really trying in
my Zoom class to make it real.
And it doesn't have
the same effect.
-Yeah.
-No.
-Do you think you dress like --
when you saw the other kids,
did you think, "I'm dressing
like kids in college now"
or, "I'm dressing like kids
from '90s movies."
-Definitely '90s movies that
I thought people dressed like
now and they don't.
Everyone was in sweatpants.
-Gotcha.
-I was the only one
in a collared shirt.
-Uh-huh. And they were like --
-Yeah. It's okay.
-"Oh, my God, that's so sad.
That's an actress."
-[ Laughs ]
I was acting like a student.
Yeah.
-Can I check in on your dogs,
please?
-Oh, yes. Thank you. That's
so kind of you to remember.
-Well, we've talked about
your dogs.
You have three poodles,
all of whom are so good at
posing for photographs.
-Yes. That is Jack King,
Ruler of All Floof,
Starlight Rosebud,
Hella-good-boy
Gonna-need-a-big-bank.
And "Ten-Four Ladybird
keep the madness rolling."
-Okay, now,
what do you call them
if you have to, like,
talk to them quickly?
-Well, last time,
she really didn't have a name
because she doesn't really
remember it.
So we call her Ladybird
or Little.
This is Buddy and that's Jack.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-And so, what are the ages
of your dogs here?
-He's about 5, 3, and 2.
-Okay, gotcha.
And one of them
has a very special skill.
Who is the yodeler?
-The little one
is in love with him,
and so when he barks a lot,
she likes to sing to him.
She croons.
She's in love, you know.
She just wants him
to notice her.
It's very romantic.
-And do you feel like he's
barking, do you think she's --
do you think her crooning
is to calm him down
or just to, like,
be in duet with him?
In your head,
what are you picturing?
-[ Howls ]
[ Laughs ]
What does that say, you know?
Like, "I love you. Notice me."
I don't know.
-We actually have videos.
-Oh.
-Should we let the whole
audience decide what this --
this true just sort of
expression of love.
-The expression,
Valentine's Day.
Happy Valentine's Day.
-Okay, let's see it.
[ Dogs barking ]
-It really is love.
-Doesn't it feel like love?
-Yeah.
-I feel like she's saying,
"What you're looking for
isn't out there.
It's right here on the bed,
man."
-"I'm here. Right here.
Why don't you see me?"
-Last thing, I know
this is a question I'm asking
knowing full well
you'll avoid it, but phase 5
of Marvel is very exciting
-Very exciting.
-Young Avengers.
People talk about the idea
of Young Avengers.
-What are you talking about?
-I'm just saying if
there was going to be something
like that,
would you be interested?
-I don't know. Would I?
I mean, like, what?
The thing that's cool was making
this movie was the best project
of my life, and even if
I'm lucky enough to do
another Marvel movie,
nothing will ever top
working with Paul Rudd
everyday.
-There you go.
-Ever. So, I don't know.
-Alright, well,
we're certainly happy
you made time for us,
on your birthday no less.
-[ Laughs ] On my birthday.
Happy birthday.
-Happy birthday to you.
It's so cool we share it.
-I know!
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-You guys,
that's Kathryn Newton.
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania,"
will be in theaters and IMAX
on Friday, February 17th.
And we'll be right back
with more "Late Night."